le collègue l'ordre du jour appelle la
question orale de Monsieur Philippe
Leroy transmise à monsieur le ministre
chargé du budget
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
l'article 13,95 e du Code Général des
Impôts
issus de la loi de développement des
territoires ruraux adoptés en 2005 une
prévoit l'exonération des taxes
foncières sur les propriétés en ont bâti
situé en zone Natura 2000 en matière
forestière les sites Natura 2000
concernent essentiellement des communes
peuplées
et à fort taux de boisement ou la tnfb
représente le plus gros des revenus
l'exonération des taxes précisées de
taxes précitées fait l'objet par la loi
d'une compensation pour les communes
concernées sur la base des taux votés en
2003 en principe
ce principe de compensation
constitue à l'évidence une contrainte
très forte pour l'État une obligation
pour l'État cependant dépit de
nombreuses protestations la compensation
a été intégrée depuis 2009 au périmètre
des variables d'ajustement qui
permettent de respecter pour l'État
l'évolution de l'enveloppe normée de ces
concours aux collectivités
de fait au détriment des communes
concernées par la forêt cette
compensation a été réduite
progressivement et n'apportait en 2013
que sur 51% de la perte de recettes et
la situation évoluera dans le même sens
en 2014
pour les forêts le ministère des
Finances s'obstine à ne pas vouloir
exclure l'exonération Natura 2000 du
périmètre des variables d'ajustement et
renie ainsi les engagements de l'État au
bénéfice des politiques aux politiques
environnementales en conséquence on
risque un rejet de la politique Natura
2000 pour les communes forestières
concernées souvent pauvres qui
connaissent là un manque à gagner
considérable qu'on estime à un million
d'euros en 2014
je demande à Monsieur les ministres
concernés
l'Économie des Finances l'aménagement
durable de bien vouloir exclure
l'exonération d'un Natura 2000 des
variables d'ajustement pour les terres
forestières
collègues la parole est à Madame George
Paul Langevin mini chargé de la réussite
éducative
du Premier ministre les collectivités
territoriales on consenti un effort de 1
milliard 5 d'euros dès 2014 sur les
concours financiers de l'Etat ainsi les
collectivités locales participeront à
l'effort de rétablissement des comptes
publics mis en œuvre par le gouvernement
dans ce contexte il n'est pas
souhaitable d'exclure des allocations
compensatrices telles que celles
relatives à l'exonération Natura 2000 de
l'assiette des variables d'ajustements
sauf à concentrer l'effort des
collectivités locales sur un nombre
restreint de variables qui risquerait de
le moindre moins soutenable pour les
collectivités qui demeuraient impacter
le périmètre large des variables
d'ajustement est ainsi un gage de
pilotage équilibré de la trajectoire des
concours de l'État ou collectivité
locale qui n'apparaît pas opportun de
déduire
vous pensez bien que votre réponse ne me
satisfait en aucune façon je voudrais
d'ailleurs
corriger si vous me le permettez avec
respect
ce que vous dites vous dites les
collectivités locales ont consenti une
baisse de leur
de leurs revenus de leur transfert d'un
milliard et demi non on a imposé contre
leur gré évidemment cette diminution de
recettes aux collectivités locales n'ont
rien consenti du tout
le fait par ailleurs pour le ministère
de souhaiter inclure incorporer dans les
variables d'ajustement des petites
communes des petites communes
forestières souvent perdus dans des
zones rurales profondes dans les seules
revenus viennent souvent de la forêt
d'intégrer ces petites communes et pour
une économie d'un million d'euros
d'intégrer ces petites communes au titre
des de toutes de toutes les autres
communes dans dans ce sacrifice fait sur
les compensations prévues par la loi et
est à mon avis un signe de non-respect
de négligence
d'oubli de petites communes profondément
ancrées dans le territoire rural
français
merci
de suspendre la séance la séance est
suspendue pour un quart d'heure
un